ja und wie schon oft die frage die sich
heute wirklich viele menschen stellen
wird die spritpreis bremse wirklich bei
den verbrauchern ankommen das
bundesfinanzministerium scheint da
relativ skeptisch und auch das
bundeskartellamt hat nun angekündigt
ganz genau hinzuschauen ob die
mineralölkonzerne den rabatt auch
wirklich an die verbraucher an die
autofahrer weitergegeben
denn die bekommen auch heute beim blick
auf die preise an der zapfsäule
einen regelrechten schock und hier sehen
wir gerade ein live bild von einer
tankstelle in berlin schauen wir uns das
genau an der dieselpreis bei zwei euro 7
super hier bei 2 euro
16 tja und wie sieht es im rest von
deutschland aus wir schauen zu unseren
spritpreis sheriffs
[Musik]
ja und customer care der ist erfurt
carsten wie ist die aktuelle situation
hat sich ja im vergleich zu unserer
letzten schalte was geändert bei dir
naja die preise sind leicht wieder
geklettert hier in erp- und ich habe
auch wieder nachgeguckt an den 26
tankstellen die die landeshauptstadt
thüringens ihr zu bieten hat also liegen
wir jetzt bei einem durchschnittspreis
bei super von 2 eur 29 das ist ja wieder
ein bisschen mehr als heute früh und ich
stehe hier mit dem herrn zarhuber der
hat nämlich gerade getankt und ich will
ihnen gerne mal fragen darüber haben sie
denn heute vollgetankt weil sie wissen
dass der tank rabatt kommt nein habe ich
nicht
der tank war einfach so leer das
betanken mussten und deswegen haben wir
jetzt ein bisschen rein getankt so dass
für die nächsten ein zwei tage reicht
und dann schauen wir mal wie es wird wie
sie es entwickelt was erhoffen sie sich
genau vor dem tank rabatt wird er
wirklich durchschlagen oder wie ist ihre
meinung
man hört jetzt schon wieder dass die
preise wieder steigen sollen also es
kann wahrscheinlich keiner genau
vorhersagen dies sein wird
vielen dank herr zachhuber also die
leute in erfurt auch sind skeptisch das
muss man mal dazu sagen und wir werden
gespannt sein wie sich der morgige tag
dann tatsächlich abspielen wird weil
viele tankstellen besitzer wie gesagt
mit denen ich gesprochen habe ihre tanks
entweder jetzt schon voll gefüllt haben
aber da können sie dann den preis nicht
den tank rabatt nicht voll weitergeben
oder andere lassen den tank halb leer
und hoffen dann dass sie dann wirklich
benzin aus den raffinerien bekommen
allerdings mit dem großen risiko dass
irgendwann das benzin alle sein könnte
also wir werden hier auf alle fälle auch
in erfurt weiter beobachten für euch
carsten noch eine kurze nachfrage denn
die situation ist wirklich sehr sehr
skurril und du hast sie auch gerade
diskutiert mit dem autofahrer der ihn
bei dir stand denn er sagt er zeigt voll
weil morgen der tankwarte com erklär uns
noch mal bitten achten auf den punkt die
situation was wird morgen passieren
also morgen
wird es zu sein also an der tankstelle
wo wir jetzt hier stehen ist es so die
haben also wirklich den tank die tanks
ihrer tankstelle gestern noch mal voll
getankt aber das ist teures benzin und
teures diesel das heißt sie müssen erst
mal dieses teure benzin dieses teure
diesel verkaufen erst danach hat mir der
tankstellenbesitzer gesagt kann er sich
dann um preiswerteres benzin und diesel
von den raffinerien kümmern da gehen
aber einige tage ins land das heißt der
tankstellenbesitzer hier geht davon aus
dass also eigentlich zu keinem fall
morgen schon der große tank rabatt wohl
durchschlagen könnte
deswegen sind die leute auch so
skeptisch und tank noch voll
dankeschön kosten für diese
einschätzungen
und wir wollen das thema natürlich jetzt
noch ein bisschen vertiefen fragen uns
natürlich auch wie wird das seien mit
den mineralölkonzernen
hätten sie den rabatte wirklich
weitergeben oder nicht dazu sind wir
jetzt mit thomas bareiß verbunden dem
verkehrsexperten der unionsfraktion
schönen guten tag herr bareiß
wenn sie mich ansprechen ich bin nicht
herr heiße ich bin der engelhart pgl
wenn sie jetzt gerade wird unterbrochen
sind dann sprechen wir später mit herrn
war als oder das wollen wir erst mal mit
ihnen sprechen sie sind vorne
brummifahrer verbannte vgl und natürlich
trifft sie diese ganze verteuerung
natürliche extremen er wie sehen sie die
situation für die brummifahrer momentan
also für unsere branche ich vertrete den
bgl den bundesverband güterkraftverkehr
logistik und entsorgung wir sind der
spitzenverband des deutschen
transportgewerbes wir haben massive
probleme bei uns in der branche selbst
wenn der rabatt komplett weitergegeben
würde sind das lediglich 14 respektive
der mehrwertsteuer 17 cent das reicht
natürlich bei weitem nicht aus wir haben
eine extreme kostensteigerung von über
25 bis stellenweise 30 prozent im
vergleich zum letzten jahr zu verkraften
und viele unternehmen aus dem
transportgewerbe werden ihre
fahrzeugflotte minimieren einige
unternehmen sind auch schon in die
insolvenz gegangen und das ist ein
riesenproblem für die versorgung unserer
bevölkerung wir haben im moment schon
das problem dass uns 80.000 kraftfahrer
fehlen wenn jetzt noch diese extreme
kostensteigerung im energiesektor dazu
kommt dann haben wir ganz massive
probleme die versorgung in zukunft
aufrecht zu erhalten
ja
wir haben hier konkrete vorschläge
gemacht und zwar richten die sich
besonders an die politik in berlin und
brüssel aber hier in dem fall vorrangig
an berlin wir fordern einen gewerbe
diesel also keine lösung mit der
gießkanne sondern eine entsprechende
staatliche hilfe für besonders
betroffene unternehmen zb haben wir in
deutschland derzeit 7000 gas lkws sind
lkws
haben sich die preise für das an den
entsprechenden kraftstoff in dem fall
das flüssiggas sogar verdreifacht diese
unternehmen brauchen eine staatliche
subvention damit die zukünftigen noch
die transporte durch werden können dann
haben wir etliche mittelständler über 80
prozent der transporte in deutschland
werden von kleinen und mittelständischen
transportunternehmen
durchgeführt die ein bis 20 angestellte
haben das sind unternehmen dabei die zum
beispiel auch für staatliche konzerne
jahres kontrakte also jahres verträge
unterschrieben haben die können die
gestiegenen kraftstoffkosten auch nicht
eins zu eins weitergeben und für diese
unternehmen fordern wir entsprechend
staatliche subventionen aber nicht mit
der gießkanne sondern zielgerichtet bei
dem entsprechenden nachweis der
bedürftigkeit das würde der branche sehr
stark helfen weil ihre persönliche
einschätzung auch als bürger als
verbraucher was glauben sie werden die
mineralölkonzerne tatsächlich die
vergünstigung weitergeben oder werden
sie sich weder in die eigene tasche
stecken da wird mit sicherheit ein teil
der subventionen auch bei den
mineralölkonzernen hängen bleiben und
ich kann nur die bevölkerung davor
warnen unsere transportbranche ist sehr
angespannt neben den kraftstoffkosten
die explodieren fehlen uns über 80.000
berufskraftfahrer wenn wir nicht schnell
was für den deutschen mittelstand an
maßnahmenpaketen auf den weg bringen
werden wir ganz schnell englische
verhältnisse bekommen und da hat jeder
glaube ich noch die bilder vor augen was
dort vor den tankstellen in supermärkten
et cetera sich abgespielt hat und es ist
fünf vor zwölf da müssen wir jetzt ganz
schnell handeln und das richtet sich
vorrangig an das wirtschaftsministerium
flankiert durch das verkehrsministerium
die vorschläge liegen dort auf dem tisch
es wird jetzt dringend zeit dass für
diese weiter umsetzen
kein problem
verbunden dem verkehrsexperten der
unionsfraktion
haben sie gerade schon verwechselt ja
was meinen sie denn wie es denn ihre
einschätzung kommen diese entlastungen
von der politik groß angekündigt
tatsächlich jetzt ab morgen bei uns bei
den pendler bei den autofahrern bei den
bürgern an oder machen die
mineralölkonzerne da nicht mit
es dinge die das tun müssen ankommen
will ich glaube dass die leistung mehr
gemacht werden um die menschen vor ort
auch wirklich auch von den hohen
energiepreisen und spritfressende bay zu
entlasten dass auch da ich habe zu
arbeiten aber auch die vier tage
gelegenheit auch eine bezahlbare und der
jetzt wird es darum gehen das würde dich
darauf schauen dass die spritpreise
wirklich die kritik nächsten zwei drei
tage um den betrag bin auch dann die die
steuersenkung genau betrieb stehen auch
wirklich reduziert wird das hat auch
beobachtet werden müssen das
bundeskartellamt hat ihr ganz klar noch
mal gesagt sie wollen hier auch diese
preise noch einmal die brise prüfen
wünsche aber das heißt nicht dass er
irgendwie gewinnen in den raffinerien
oder auch bei den tankstellen hängen
bleibt aber sagen wir mal so eine
maßnahme von der man von vornherein
eigentlich schon gar nicht so sicher ist
ob sie wirklich wirkt wo man dann auch
noch gucken muss aber am
bundeskartellamt sich dann einschaltet
das kann doch nicht die lösung sein da
müssen doch konkrete maßnahmen her um
leben wir wir es eben von 1 engelhardt
gehört haben englische verhältnisse auf
den straßen zu verhindern
dass wichtig des gesprächs beobachter
glauben jetzt keine
staatlichen mindestpreis nötig machen
oder eine preispolitik von staatlicher
seite aus ihr vornehmen das ist etwas
was wir nicht wohin deutschland ich
glaube das macht auch keinen sinn es
gibt auch die sehr hohe transparenz
übrigen auch bei den tankstellen
es gibt eine app die rate jedem unter
zulagen kann man genau sehen wie
tankstellen umfeld ihre spritpreise
derzeit auch aushängen und ganz konkret
kann man den appetit wünscht die
tankstelle suchen das spart viel geld
vor ort spricht dagegen eine hohe
transparenz und nach unten ab und dieser
muss man die gerade jetzt nutzen und da
kann man sich 67 war toten sind es
diesmal ein liter sprit hinaus behalten
aber das ist doch total die
milchmädchenrechnung eigentlich weil
jetzt erhöhen die mineralölkonzerne
gerade die preise bis ins jenseits und
dann gibt es dann ab morgen übermorgen
überübermorgen man weiß es nicht genau
diesen rabatt und alle denken dann oh
jetzt speicher wieder geld aber das ist
doch total fies
es ist einfach ist leider nicht es gibt
ja auch einmal eine hohe bei steigungen
rohöls wenn wir leiden schon im mai zehn
prozent rohöl ein steigerung das heißt
auch ist 40 regel auf dem welche
auswirkungen dies muss wie gesagt die
steuerreduzierung auch einkommen fordert
ich glaube auch dass die reduktion um
drei monate wie zu kurz ist überhaupt
noch hier längerfristige steuerreduktion
jetzt auch so dass hier der staat und
auch profitiert davon von den hohen
energiepreisen
spritpreisen wir haben einbrechen
mehrwertsteuer für benzin und diesel
mehreinnahmen von unter 4 und halb
milliarden euro in diesem jahr
vielleicht wahrscheinlich so die
berechnungen das heißt der staat
profitiert von den hohen preis und die
müssen zurückgeben werden die menschen
deshalb sind die die steuerreduktion
richtig und sind somit auch noch ihr zu
wenig welt auch wenn diese steigerung
und wirklich steuerreduktion ist eins zu
eins bei diesen benzin auch angewandt
wird sie aber immer noch höher um diese
benzinpreis als vor der ukraine krise
also davon müssen die menschen nicht
immer noch mehr zahlen als ist ja riesig
italien wenn sie jetzt sagen dass es zu
wenig heißt also sie hatten sich
eventuell eine andere lösung gewünscht
als jetzt die senkung der
mineralölsteuer wo eben doch so viel
spielraum ist man gibt zum beispiel in
italien mit anderen modellen den
verbrauchern sofort mehr freiheit indem
nämlich die preise direkt sinken warum
ist dass wir die bundesregierung
offensichtlich keine option das glauben
sie also wie gesagt ich sehe das genauso
dass man wirklich mehr machen sollte
natürlich für viele menschen ist ohnehin
freunde ganz ganz wichtigen es heute
mobilität ist das auto angewiesen
vielfach gar nicht dass deshalb die
menschen inzwischen deutlich zu großen
last geworden
ist das eine tor gemacht würden ja auch
in anderen bereichen noch hohe
preissteigerungen sehen beides heizungs
wird viele menschen auch diese treffen
das teilweise bereits für tag bis zu
drei bis viermal mehr kosten wird als
noch vor einem jahr als 1 gewann ist in
die menschen in gstaad belastet deshalb
müssen wir wirklich auch da gehen die
angewiesen sind bringen längerfristig
entlastung auch wirklich auch nötig
machen sagt thomas bareiß
verkehrsexperte der unionsfraktion
besten dank